Whether it's pulse-pounding action or gut-wrenching
drama, movies only succeed if they keep audiences
glued to what they're putting in the spotlight.
At least, that's the plan. But what happens
when a movie's best jokes, weirdest scenes,
or wittiest references are being made where
nobody should be looking? Here are Screen
Rant's 10 Hilarious Details Hidden In The
Background Of Movies.
Mr. Nanny (New Line Cinema)
Our list proves that a background actor or
extra can give a movie something special,
but when Hulk Hogan's adventure in babysitting
ends, there's only one thing viewers will
ask: was that guy throwing his dog into a
lake? The inexplicable background detail has
become a cult favorite, when Hulk's motorcycle
montage features, with no explanation, a man
tossing his pet into the water. The dog seems
more surprised and confused than actually
bothered - it's a dog, after all - but was
it planned? Was the man an actor, or was it
a total coincidence? The questions have lasted
longer than the Hulkster's career, meaning
that dog at least deserves a supporting credit…
and don’t worry no dogs were harmed during
the filming of Mr. Nanny!
Despicable Me (Universal)
The yellow minions of this movie series were
runaway hits, scoring their own film and too
many products to count. But did you know that
minions can get a little romantic when no
one's watching? When Gru and his gang are
celebrating a year of supervillainy, one minion
gets so excited, he can't help but plant a
passionate kiss on his coworker. It went over
pretty well. When their rocket makes it to
the moon later in the movie, the kisser becomes
the kissee - with the romanced minion returning
the favor.
Star Wars (Lucasfilm)
You have to hand it to Boba Fett: he's only
on screen for a minute or two of the original
Star Wars trilogy, but still just as famous
as Darth Vader or his stormtroopers. But most
fans don't realize the bounty hunter's death
is meant to make Boba Fett the butt of one
of the trilogy's best slapstick gags. They'll
remember Han Solo activating Fett's jet pack
by accident, sending him into the Sarlacc,
but Luke's lightsaber fight usually distracts
fans from the ice cold killer hilariously
flailing through the air across the frame.
Making his reputation as a no-nonsense assassin
even funnier.
Jurassic Park (Universal)
It's impossible to forget the moment that
Spielberg's massive T-Rex was revealed, changing
movie history along with it. But aside from
CG, the practical puppet of the dinosaur helped
bring the creature to life - especially as
it chowed down on a goat. We all know that
the T-Rex was just movie magic, but the scene
itself breaks the illusion a few times. The
best example? When the T-Rex throws its head
back to swallow the goat whole, and the camera
follows: revealing the sprinkler head spraying
directly onto the puppet (1:03:14). No wonder
he was so angry.
Year One (Columbia Pictures)
The final film from Ghostbusters creator Harold
Ramis wasn't a big hit with critics or audiences,
but the caveman comedy managed to sneak one
of its best jokes into the background. While
the heroes carry out a scene in front of the
camera, a background character seems to be
getting.... familiar with a goat (but not
exactly the way you'd expect). It's the actor's
excitement and silent cheer as the other extras
look on that seals the joke, even if most
viewers will miss it completely.
The LEGO Movie (Warner Bros.)
The world of LEGO can take you anywhere, but
when it comes to food, the toys have been
limited. Croissants and sausages are two ofthe
most popular solutions, since they actually
fit the LEGO figures hands. In the LEGO Movie,
the filmmakers couldn't help themselves from
making a joke with that in mind. When the
movie's heroes smash into a train in the Old
West, keep an eye on the last pig on board.
The heroes land on the train, but the pig
smashes into the ground. Bursting into a cloud
of sausages. More proof that no one ever really
dies in a world where everything is awesome.
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory (Paramount)
Who can make the world taste good? The Candy
Man can! That's according to an early song
in this kids' classic, delivered with handfuls
of candy by a candy store owner. You can tell
it's only a movie when he lets the kids help
themselves to the treats behind the counter,
but for one girl, things get VERY real. In
hindsight, she probably shouldn't have been
resting her head on the counter knowing it
was going to be opened, but seeing her drilled
in the chin - and it somehow being the best
take - is just one more reason to watch it
all over again.
The Last Samurai (Warner Bros)
It's a proven fact that animals in Hollywood
are unpredictable, and the more serious a
scene, the more trouble they'll cause. You
might have caught this one in our other video
entitled Biggest Movie Mistakes You Missed
but we just couldn’t leave it out! Fans
of Tom Cruise's Last Samurai will forever
wonder how they could have missed this unscripted
moment from the hero's horse, proving that
bullets and bombs weren't the only things
Samurai had to worry about. Apparently Tom
Cruise wasn't as gifted a rider as his horse
seemed to think, with a poor extra taking
the punishment.
Everything Must Go (Lionsgate)
It's a shame this Will Ferrell dramedy wasn't
a blockbuster hit, since even more people
could have witnessed one of the weirdest background
movie moments ever. When Ferrell's character
visits a high school friend, they carry on
their scene as her children play in the front
yard. But when the kids appear in the background
completely motionless, it's impossible to
look away. The young actors were probably
told not to be distracting and keep still,
but the result has viewers wondering if they've
suddenly stumbled into an unsettling horror
movie.
Raiders of the Lost Ark (Paramount)
Everyone knows that the infamous gun vs sword
showdown in the first Indiana Jones adventure
wasn't entirely planned, with Harrison Ford's
illness seeing the extended fight cut for
a quick gag. But the inside joke means viewers
might miss the other gem of the scene: the
world's laziest butcher over Indy's shoulder.
Sure, hammering a butchers knife in the background
of a scene would be distracting, or even dangerous.
But the weak chops the extra settled on are
distracting in an even better way.
Those are the best jokes and details we could
find hidden in the background of our favorite
movies, but which ones have we missed? Be
sure to tell us in the comments, and remember
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one!